Image formation
Now, we're going to look at a more mathematical
way to describe the projection process, projection
of a point from the real world into the image
plane. In the last lecture, we looked at it
from a very intuitive and geometric perspective.
This time, we're going to look at it more
mathematically.
We're going to use a different projection
model to what we used last time. We're going
to use a model that's referred to as the "central
projection" model. The key elements of this
model are the cameras co-ordinate frame we
denote by C. The image plane is parallel to
the camera's x and y axis and positioned at
a distance F in the positive z direction.
F is equivalent to the focal length of the
lens that we talked about in the last lecture.
Now in order to project the point, what we
do is we cast a ray from the point in the
world through the image plane to the origin
of the camera. With the central projection
model, you'll note that the image is non-inverted
as it was in the case that we talked about
in the last lecture. We can write an equation
for the point P in homogeneous coordinates,
we multiply the world coordinates, X, Y, Z
by a 3 x 4 matrix in order to get the homogeneous
coordinates of the projected point on the
image plane.
Let's look at this equation in a little bit
more detail. It's quite straightforward to
write an expression for x̃, ỹ, z̃ in terms
of the focal length and the world coordinate,
X, Y, Z. We can transform the homogeneous
coordinates to Cartesian coordinates using
the rule that we talked about in the last
section and with a little bit of rearrangement,
we can bring the equation into this form and
this is exactly the same form as we derived
in the last lecture by looking at similar
triangles.
What's really convenient and useful about
this homogeneous representation of the image
formation process is that it is completely
linear. We don't have this explicit division
by Z, the distance between the camera and
the object. It's implicit in the way we write
the equations in homogeneous form.
Let's look at this equation again and we can
factor this matrix into two. The matrix on
the right has elements that are either 0 or
1 or f, the focal length of the lens. So this
matrix performs the scaling and zooming. It’s
a function of the focal length of our lens.
The matrix on the left has got an interesting
shape, it’s only a 3 x 4 and this matrix
performs the dimensionality reduction, crunches
points from three dimensions down into two.
And so far, we consider the image plane to
be continuous. In reality, the image plane
is quantized. It consists of a massive array
of light sensing elements which corresponds
to the pixels in the output image. The dimension
of each pixel in this grid, I’m going to
denote by the Greek letter Pu. So the pixels
are Ρu wide and they’re Ρv high. Pixels
are really really small so the width and height
of a pixel is often at the order of around
10 microns, maybe a bit bigger, maybe a bit
smaller.
What we need to do now is to convert the coordinate
P which we computed previously and that was
in units of meters with respect to the origin
of the image plane.
We need to convert it to units of pixels and
our pixel coordinate system has got a different
origin as we talked about in earlier lectures.
Pixel coordinates are measured from the top-left
corner of the image so we need to do a scaling
and we need to do a shifting and that’s
a simple linear operation. So if we have the
Cartesian x and y coordinates of the point
P on the image plane, we can convert that
to the equivalent pixel coordinate which we
denote by the coordinates u and v and we can
represent that again in homogeneous form.
Here we multiplied by a matrix, the elements
of the matrix are the dimensions of the pixel
Pu and Pv and the coordinates of what’s
called the principal point. The principal point is
the pixel coordinate where the z
axis of the camera origin frame
pierces the image plane. The homogeneous pixel coordinates can be converted
to the more familiar Cartesian pixel coordinates
u and v by the transformation rule that we
covered earlier.
Essentially, we take the first and second
element of the homogeneous vector and divide
it by the third element of the homogeneous
vector.
Now, we can put all these pieces together
and we can write the complete camera model
in terms of three matrices. The product of
the first two matrices is typically denoted
by the symbol K and we refer to these as the
intrinsic parameters. All the numbers in these
two matrices are functions of the camera itself.
It doesn't matter where the camera is where
it’s pointing, they’re only a function
of the camera. These numbers include the height
and width of the pixels on the image plane,
the coordinates of the principal point and
the focal length of the lens.
The third matrix describes the extrinsic parameters
and these describe where the camera is but
they don’t say anything about the type of
camera.
The elements in this matrix are a function
of the relative pose of the camera with respect
to the world origin frame. In fact, it is
the inverse of xi C.
The product of all of these matrices together
is referred to as the camera matrix and it’s
often given the symbol C.
So this single matrix, this single 3 x 4 matrix
is all we need to describe the mapping from
a world coordinate, X, Y and Z through to
a homogeneous representation of the pixel
coordinate on the image plane. That homogeneous
image plane coordinate can be converted to
the familiar Cartesian image plane coordinate
using this transformation rule here. So this
is a very simple and concise way of performing
perspective projection.
Let’s consider now what happens when I introduce
a non-zero scale factor λ. The homogeneous
coordinate elements ũ, ṽ and w̃ will
all be scaled by λ. When I convert them to
Cartesian form, the λ term will be factored
out, it's in the numerator and the denominator so
the result will be unchanged. This is a particular
advantage of writing the relationship in homogeneous
form. It gives us what’s called scaling variance.
Because we can multiply the matrix by an arbitrary
scale factor, it means we can write the camera
matrix in a slightly simplified form, which
we refer to as a normalized camera matrix.
We do that by choosing one particular element
of that matrix to have a value of 1 and typically
we choose the bottom right element and set it to 1.
This normalized camera matrix still contains
all of the information to completely describe
the image formation process. It contains the
focal length of the lens, it contains the
dimensions of the pixels, it contains the
coordinate of the principal point and it contains
the position and orientation of the camera
in three dimensional space. And finally, we can convert the homogeneous pixel coordinates
to the more familiar Cartesian pixel coordinates
which we denote by u and v.